PETE LEPAGE: Welcome,
everybody.
My name is Pete LePage, and I'm
a developer advocate on
the Chrome team.
Today we've got another exciting
episode of our Chrome
Apps Office Hours.
I'm joined by Paul Kinlan
who's in London.
Paul, I'll let you introduce
yourself.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes, I'm Paul
Kinlan in London.
I'm also a Chrome Developer
advocate at Google, and we've
got a really exciting episode
today about identity and
managing identity inside
Chrome applications.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, I think so.
Awesome.
So let's just introduce the
identity stuff in Chrome apps,
because I think that's
a fairly important
thing to talk about.
Because Chrome apps, if you want
to authenticate against a
Google app, there's a real easy
way-- or a Google service
or anything like that, there's
a real easy way you can go
about doing that.
It's a pretty quick way to go.
But if you want to authenticate
against anything
else, if you say you wanted to
authenticate against Twitter,
maybe your own service, maybe
you want to authenticate--
today, we're actually going to
take a look at Instagram.
But if you want to be able to
authenticate against those so
that you can make sure, hey,
this user has rights to do
this and maybe upload files,
these are things that are
really important that
you're going to want
to be able to do.
As we go through today, I just
put up some links to some of
the documentation that
we've got going.
As always, we always want to
hear about your questions.
The link to questions is
up there right now.
You can ask your questions
at that URL.
We'll be keeping an eye on
there during the day.
It's actually, Paul,
it's right there.
So--
PAUL KINLAN: Oh yeah, I'm
looking the wrong way.
PETE LEPAGE: --yeah,
it's to your--
I'm not even going
to try and guess.
PAUL KINLAN: I was trying
to be cool.
PETE LEPAGE: I think it's to
your lower right, if you look
to your lower right.
There you go.
Alright, perfect.
Awesome.
So why don't I pass it over to
Paul, and you can start with a
little introduction of the stuff
that you've got going.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, so identity,
identity, identity.
It's what we're trying
to talk about today.
One of the things that we
noticed when we've been
building web applications,
especially inside Chrome and
Chrome Extensions over the past
couple years, is that
it's actually pretty hard to
authenticate against a third
party service.
And these third party services
like Pete mentioned before
were like Twitter, or Instagram,
or Facebook, things
that aren't necessarily Google
properties, they've always
been a little bit hard
to authenticate
against OAuth 1.0.
The OAuth 1.0 flow doesn't
quite work very well for
installed applications,
applications not necessarily
with a server behind
the scenes.
And obviously, OAuth 2.0 has
come along as well, and people
want to take advantage of OAuth
2.0, and not have to
have any specific integrations
into the browser for those
external APIs.
But you build to authenticate
and interact with these APIs
themselves.
So we've introduced this
experimental--
it's still experimental
at the moment--
identity API.
And the identity API is like
pizza, it's split into two
bits, the Google service area,
where you can ask for access
to Docs and a whole lot of other
stuff like that, and
then the third party flows
where that's the
Twittergrams-- ah, that's
a new one--
Instagram, Twitter, Facebook,
all those types of services.
And that's the one we're going
to talk about today.
It's a really simple API.
The reason why we're doing it
is we want to make it super
simple for you, when you're
building an installed
application, to be able to
authenticate against a third
party service without tons and
tons and tons of code.
We've all been burned
by OAuth 1.0.
OAuth 2.0 is a lot easier.
But you've got to remember,
a lot of services don't
necessarily use just OAuth
for authentication.
They might use OpenID, they
might use Basic Auth, loads of
different types of
authentication.
We think that the way we've
designed this third party
authentication system is in a
way that it enables you to be
able to authenticate and
basically use any type of
authentication process that
you could think of.
We're going to look at OAuth
2.0 today inside Instagram.
Should we just jump into
the application for
the rest of the show?
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah,
let's do that.
I'm bringing up your screen now
so they see your screen.
PAUL KINLAN: That's my screen,
these are all my apps, there's
a lot of installed applications
there.
We have a very nice
MarkDown editor.
I'd try that one out.
PETE LEPAGE: That MarkDown
editor is pretty sweet.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah,
it's pretty cool.
IRC app as well.
Anyway, that's not what we're
talking about today.
We are doing this
thing called--
I called it On Air
Authentication
because I had two apps.
One was a test app, which I've
just realized doesn't load,
but this one does.
So this one works.
And this is the worst looking
application you will see in
your lifetime today, but it's
going to be something that
we're going to show you the
potential of the API.
Click some buttons, doesn't
do anything.
You would also expect, with an
Instagram API, to be able to
view photos and a whole
lot of other stuff.
However, that's not going to
work, because that is an
exercise for you, the listener,
the watcher, the
reader to actually implement.
But what we're going
to show you is--
PETE LEPAGE: I think they're
actually viewers, Paul.
PAUL KINLAN: Sorry?
PETE LEPAGE: I think
they're viewers.
PAUL KINLAN: Did
I say watchers?
PETE LEPAGE: Watchers, yes.
PAUL KINLAN: Oh, my.
That's terrible--
PETE LEPAGE: That's OK, it's
always fun like that.
I'm giving you trouble.
PAUL KINLAN: It's the English
way of saying it.
Anyway, sorry.
So this is the application that
we're going to fill out,
and basically by the end of it,
we'll see an authenticated
stream of data coming back in.
It'll just be JSON, raw JSON
data, but you'll be able to
see the fact that you can
get this information.
You can authenticate against the
service, and then start to
interact with it, and build
your own things.
One of the reasons that we
haven't got images is we can't
directly pull images
in for content
security policy reasons.
And Paul Lewis has written a
really good library that
enables it to do this,
but it's out the
scope of this talk.
So jumping into the code, what
do we have to do to get
identity working?
Well, it's actually
pretty simple.
We have an app.
I've already made the shell of
the app, so it's the outside
parts of it where--
basically, I don't want to bore
you kind of showing you
how to create applications,
because you already
know how to do it.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, we've done a
bunch of Hangouts and Office
Hours before where we've walked
through the Hello World.
If you haven't seen one, you
can go back to all the GDL
events before.
You can grab one of those.
If not, there's a good Hello
World app in the
documentation.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, and you can
use Yeoman, yeoman init Chrome
apps, or Chrome app, those types
of things, which I've
done with this actually.
Which is why there's a picture
of Yeoman as the icon.
So anyway, the first thing that
we always do when we're
building applications is just
check out the manifest.
This is a basic manifest.
It's using some localized
variables.
We can ignore them a little
bit at the moment.
An app background script, the
thing that always runs there.
And there's this weird thing
here which normally most
people don't play around with,
especially when you upload
into the store, called a key.
The key is the public key,
basically, of your
application, and it's used
for authentication and
verification that the installed
application or
extension that you've got is
authentic, essentially.
The reason why we need this is
that we need a consistent ID
to be able to actually test our
application, because what
normally happens in the OAuth
flow is that you will
authenticate against a service
such as Instagram, and then it
will redirect the user
back to a web page.
And our web page-- well, it
doesn't actually exist.
It's a Chrome Extension
URL, essentially.
So we need to know what that
URL is ahead of time.
And the easiest way to do it,
and the easiest way to make
sure that your ID is consistent
across even all
your machines is to generate
it yourself.
And I want to show you a little
tip to actually go off
and generate one.
You might not be able to see
this too well-- and I've just
done the volume by mistake--
is if we go in here, I think
it's atob actually.
Test.
Can't spell, it doesn't
really matter.
There we are.
Got it wrong already,
btoa, btoa.
Wow, there we go.
And that will generate a
Base64 encoded string.
And the Base64 encoded string is
what you need for your key
inside your manifest.
You can put whatever you want
inside of here when you are
testing for general
testing purposes.
It doesn't really matter what
you use as long as it's a
basic full encoded string.
However, never ever publish
that to the store.
If you're going to publish this
to the Chrome Web Store,
make sure you just delete the
key outside of your manifest,
and the Chrome Web Store will
manage that itself.
Which will mean that you have
to go and often change your
redirect URLs inside your
authentication provider, but
that's generally OK.
That's a nice quick way of doing
it inside Chrome itself.
So let's jump back
to the code.
There's the key, and we
have permissions.
And the permissions are these
things that basically say
upfront what your application
requires from the user to be
able to operate.
Now, you'd think that
an identity
permission would be needed.
Right now it's not.
You just need this thing
called an experimental
permission.
And the reason why you need this
is because you need to
basically--
excuse me.
The identity API is behind
an experimental flag,
essentially, at the moment, so
you need this flag here to be
able to actually use it.
This also means you can't upload
to the Web Store today,
but soon that'll hopefully
change.
OK, so that's our manifest.
We've got to the point where we
can do something inside our
application, or describe
what we need inside our
application.
Let's look at the index.html.
Doesn't do much.
If we go right down to the
bottom, you'll see the words
"Step1", which is the header.
There's a button that when it's
clicked we will launch an
authentication flow and a pre.
And the pre is just for nice
pretty printing, essentially.
There's not much else that we
need inside this application.
It doesn't need to look fancy,
so that's all there is.
But interestingly, there is
an index.js which is our
functionality.
And this is what we're going
to fill out today.
So if we do this right,
I will put
console.log("HELLO") in here.
And if we go back to Chrome, we
reload the app, login, and
inspect the element, we should
get console.log.
That proves we're doing
the live thing, right?
In theory.
So what's next?
So what we need to do is,
basically, we need to actually
start to actually provide the
information that we need to
authenticate.
So I'm going to make a var id.
This is going to sound a little
bit cryptic right now,
but basically it's the identity
credentials that we need.
And the first thing that you
need is actually a URL, and
the URL is the thing
that we're going to
authenticate against.
To spare my hair, because I have
none, let me just copy
and paste something
very quickly.
Oops a daisy, wrong one.
Delete that, delete
that as well.
Var id =, boom, there we are.
Now this is actually the
Instagram authentication end
point, and as you can see
we've got a client ID.
I will be deleting this
client ID after this
presentation, at least.
But the client ID is part of
the OAuth 2.0 process. it's
the thing that you need to
identify your application to
the third party service.
And the way that you actually
do that is you go to the
Instagram developer
documentation-- it's a pretty
nice documentation--
and then you look at
your applications.
I did have my application
up before.
API console, nope.
That's not the one.
Help.
Hey.
PETE LEPAGE: So these are--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PETE LEPAGE: --these are that
thing that you have to do,
Paul, to initially set your app
up with whatever service
provider if it's using
OAuth 2.0, right?
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah,
exactly right.
So what we've got here
is a client ID.
This is the thing that you
present to the your
application, client secret
which I will be deleting
pretty much straight away, the
website URL, that's just
basically to prove who you are
essentially, and then the
redirect URL.
Now the redirect URL is the
thing that Instagram will
redirect you back
to, essentially.
Let me go back here, if we
can zoom in, the zoom
doesn't work anymore.
It's a weird URL.
It's not HTTP URL, it's a
Chrome Extension URL.
PETE LEPAGE: Can you just move
that up a little bit, Paul.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, sure.
PETE LEPAGE: There we go.
That's good, yup.
PAUL KINLAN: Cool, so we have
this weird little URL, which
is a Chrome Extension URL, and
this is why we need that
consistent ID.
That thing that we put in the
manifest to generate a nice
ID, that's what we need to be
able to basically send the
user from Instagram back
into our Chrome app.
PETE LEPAGE: Right, so that
redirects into a Chrome app.
So if you think about normally
with a web app you go to a
specific URL, with a Chrome
packaged app, it's URL, even
though it's not visible to the
user ever, is that sort of
Chrome app URL.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, exactly.
Yeah, that's right.
It's just this thing to,
basically, let the other app
return into your application.
Now, the interesting thing is
that you don't necessarily
have to have a Chrome Extension
URL, it's just that
Instagram have enabled it so
that you can have any kind of
protocol, any scheme.
We do have a service--
it's not live and ready for
users or developers to play
with-- where we will host
the redirect URL for the
developer, essentially.
So it would extension ID dot--
I think it's chromiumapps.org.
So you put that in, essentially,
and all that
Chrome's doing behind the
scenes, all the application
framework is doing behind
scenes, is listening out for
either a redirect into its
application using the Chrome
Extension URL, or a redirect
into HTTPS:/ whatever it is.
PETE LEPAGE: OK, so
that way if--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PETE LEPAGE: --some third party
provider forces you to
use HTTPS, you can still make it
work because our schema is
Chrome Extension?
PAUL KINLAN: Yes, exactly right,
you can make it work
that way, and that's some
infrastructure we'll be providing.
So let me just quickly
jump out.
The next thing that we're going
to do after putting the
URL in is this thing
called interactive.
This is just a special flag
which basically says, should
the browser or should the run
time pop up, a special little
window that you can
control which
presents the login details.
If you say interactive equals
false, then you won't see
anything on the screen at all.
Now, the reason why you might
want false is not necessarily
in the OAuth flow, but
if there's some other
authenticating scheme where
you know the user based on
information that they put in
from that URL, maybe it's like
a username-password combination
or some secret token--
I mean it's a really bad
way of saying it.
You might not always need
this kind of pop up.
It doesn't make that
much sense.
You don't need a pop up to
come up to the user to
authenticate them because
they've already presented the
details that they need inside
your application.
Interactive false will
never do the pop
up, it'll just redirect.
It'll do the things it needs to
do on this remote server,
and then bring yourself back
in the application once the
redirect's happened.
So that's all it's doing.
It's not anything too sexy, but
it's kind of interesting.
Now, there's not much
to show you.
I could go off and show
you this working.
It just would not do anything
at the moment because we're
not actually doing the
authentication flow.
This is the important
piece that you need
in the whole flow.
This is the API basically where
you go launch web--
what I'd do for IntelliSense.
PETE LEPAGE: Well, why aren't
you using Sublime or
something like that?
PAUL KINLAN: I never got around
to even trying it.
You get stuck with your favorite
preferred text
editor, which is BIM, and I
don't even have any sensible
defaults in this one either.
Brand new machine.
But this is it, right?
Let's see if this works,
console.log, URL, sorry.
So what happens here
is that we have the
chrome.experimental.identity
object namespace,
launchWebAuthFlow is the
method that we call.
We pass in the details of the
thing that we want to call, so
the ID object, which is
basically the information
about Instagram, and
then a call back.
The interesting thing about this
is the parameter in the
callback that you'll receive
once authentication is
successful is a URL.
Now, you might think that's a
little bit weird, but actually
what happens is, especially in
the OAuth flow, is that the
URL contains normally the
authentication token--
sorry, not the authentication
token, the access token.
But it must also include some
things like a session ID or
whatever you need to basically
have access to the user's
object store at least.
So right, should we try
and give this a go?
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: Yay.
We don't need Insta--
we might need Instagram,
actually.
Let me just edit this, because
we do actually have a new
extension ID.
This is what we've been talking
about is where- I
think the extension ID which
is here at the bottom.
You can't really see it
probably, but on our
authentication, it's got
a unique identifier.
I'm going to just put that in
there for the description, and
the redirect URL is going
in the back into my app.
I'm going update the client.
And away we go.
So step one, if this all
works, reload app.
Here's our code.
So let me go back there so
you can see the screen.
PETE LEPAGE: And as a reminder
for folks, as they're watching
this, if you have questions, if
you're curious about some
of the things that are going on,
please post your questions
to our Google Moderator page.
The link is right there
on screen right now.
PAUL KINLAN: Hey,
so here we go.
So what's happened here is
essentially we've gone through
part of the OAuth flow and the
redirect URL of my extension
doesn't match what is supposed
to be registered.
So let me go back, I think I
know what the problem is.
PETE LEPAGE: So this is the
particular case where our app,
when we say, hey, we want
to authenticate against
something, we have to give it
where we want to redirect to.
And on the Instagram side, the
store where they think we want
to redirect to.
And so we make sure--
I'm covering myself with
the little image
there, there we go--
so they make sure that both
of those are identical.
And if they're not identical,
they say, oh, screw you, got
to go, get out of here, we're
not going to actually work.
PAUL KINLAN: Yup, exactly.
Basically what's happened is
I've constructed the wrong URL
inside my request.
Because the extension ID changed
between me testing
this and me actually just
updating the variables before.
So if all works well--
let's get rid of, no,
the new tab is fine,
developers tool is fine.
Reload app and I'm really
nervous now because if this
doesn't work then--
there we go, right.
So we've got the URL.
Now, what actually happened
here is I've been
a little bit sneaky.
Not too sneaky, because I'm
already logged into Instagram
so let me log out.
PETE LEPAGE: So you didn't see
anything pop up or anything
like that because you're
already logged in and
Instagram said oh hey, you're
already logged in, we know who
this guy is, feel free to--
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, exactly.
That is exactly right.
So Instagram knew I was already
logged in, so all they
said was cool, you're logged in,
redirect back to the app
and away you go.
So if this works, we'll
do the log in there.
PETE LEPAGE: So now we get that
dialog that pops up that
asks us to log in.
This is this interactive
dialogue that you were talking
about before.
So if you had set that
interactive to false, this
thing wouldn't pop up,
and we wouldn't be
able to log in, correct?
PAUL KINLAN: Yes, exactly.
So the interesting thing here
as well is that, actually,
what's happened is that we've
got a full screen window as
well, pretty much.
You, as the application
developer, can control the
size of the window and the
position, so if you wanted it
to pop up in the middle of your
screen and just small and
tight, you can do that.
So we offer that, certainly.
And we go back, let's have
a look at the code.
There we go.
So we've got this URL.
So basically what's happened is
we look at the JavaScript--
let me hide that.
We've gone into this call back
here with the URL being passed
back in and now we've got the
ability to do some extra
little bits and pieces of magic,
essentially, because we
now have the access token.
The access token, as you can
see it here, is in the
document fragment at
the end of the URL.
So should we try and do
something nice with the
Instagram API just to prove
that's it worked?
We've authenticated,
but we don't know
actually if it works.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, let's.
PAUL KINLAN: Here we go, cool.
So there's going to be a little
bit of code which might
not look like it makes sense to
start off with, but I know
you're all smart and you'll be
able to pick it up, even if I
don't explain it very well.
So let's make a variable
called access token.
We know the access token is on
the URL, it'll pass back in.
So we'll just do a sub
string URL.index of--
oh, dear.
Sorry.
What is it?
It was the hash sign,
or the pound sign
as you say in America.
Is that what you say
in America, pound?
PETE LEPAGE: Pound,
hash, number sign.
PAUL KINLAN: Number sign.
Well, there we go.
So basically, what we've done is
we've been really not that
robust at all in the sense that
this will fall over if
you try to use this
in production.
PETE LEPAGE: So I was going to
ask what happens if I were to
either provide a bad password
and it didn't let me log in or
if maybe I was offline, there
was no connection?
PAUL KINLAN: So actually,
I've never actually
tested it with offline.
The thing that's happened in the
past generally is that the
URL would be blank.
Basically a null
and undefined.
So if you get the point where
it's null undefined, then it
won't work.
But if your offline, the weird
thing is it only really ever
fires when there's a redirect
back into app, so it's kind of
like you could be hanging
around waiting.
It might make sense to have some
more unsuccess, unfailure
methods, because you want to
know where log ins failed, on
one side and not the other.
So if anyone wants to provide
that feedback more publicly--
I can do it, whatever you
want to, it's cool.
So this is a little something
I learned off [? Mehi ?]
[? Paparita, ?]
who is no longer with us.
He is no longer with
the Chrome team.
I think he's working for
someone else now.
He made a nice little API
wrapper around Foursquare, and
so I've done the same type of
thing here where I've made an
Instagram API.
It's not going to do too much,
but it's just going to
basically make it a little bit
easier to make requests, make
it a little bit more
sane if you want
to call more functions.
So this is our request
method, arguments.
So it's going to look very bad
when you see it because I
don't actually use arguments,
but here we go.
PETE LEPAGE: So, Paul,
one just quick--
yup, you got it.
Never mind.
PAUL KINLAN: So xhr= new XML--
I never get that, there we are,
that's the right one.
And now all we're doing is,
and I'll show you why I'm
doing this in a minute actually,
but we're just
making it so that we can
make xhr requests.
And we'll call the call back
with some xhr.response.
There we are.
Just like that.
It's not doing too
much just yet.
Xhr.open, it's a get request
at the moment.
Obviously this API was to be
fleshed out a little bit more.
You might want to do posts, when
you're posting data, but
I'm not doing that just yet.
Instagram.com/v1 if I am
remembering correctly.
And then the way that they do
the methods is that they'll
have a /user, /fetch, all
those type of things.
I tell you now, this does not
look very sexy at the moment.
PETE LEPAGE: Well, you know
what, it'll be sexy when you
make it work.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes, it's
going to be cool.
So I'm just going to move it
up a little bit so just in
case people can't see it.
Access token, right, it's going
to be asynchronous so we
don't need to put anything in.
xhr.send.
There we go.
That's it, so cool.
And I'm going to leave a bug
in, and see if anyone spots
what is once we get to it.
New Instagram.
So we're going to call
Instagram now.
Instagram, with the access
token in the constructor,
because we're going to use
that for our method call.
api.request("use
rs/self/fetch").
Oh, no it's not, it's "feed",
undefined, So I can't design
APIs to save my life, that
shouldn't even exist, but
there we go.
I thought it would be a good
idea that when I was designing
this Instagram API to
put an undefined in.
Console.log(data).
What else can we do?
Output.
So output is the dump element,
which is the pre-- the thing
we showed earlier on today.
The JSON.stringify--
PETE LEPAGE: I like the
"strongify", that would be
kind of cool.
I want to make it so strong.
[ROARING]
PAUL KINLAN: OK, so stringify.
And then last week I learned
that this exists.
You put "null, 4".
It will use taps or I think,
four spaces and pretty print
the JSON object.
Did not know that
last week, and I
learned it just for this.
PETE LEPAGE: And this is
available in Chrome?
PAUL KINLAN: I think it's just
generally available in the
APIs, so Chrome, Firefox,
and other browsers.
Should we see if this works?
PETE LEPAGE: Let's reload our
app and see if it works.
PAUL KINLAN: Reload it.
Let's get some source
control--
source control?
Source view on.
I've already spotted
the mistake.
Did anyone pick it up?
PETE LEPAGE: Nobody picked it up
in any of the comments that
I'm seeing, and nobody's posted
it in the questions.
So, I don't know.
PAUL KINLAN: There we go.
Reload.
Inspect element.
That's how live this is.
PETE LEPAGE: Got to love
live broadcasts.
PAUL KINLAN: Let's move
this up there.
A little hint for everyone, if
you create a window, give it
an ID, and then it will stick.
It will stay stuck in the place
that you last left it,
rather than what I have to
do, which is just reload
this all the time.
So let's put one in there so
we know that we're going to
get the token back.
method, access token,
access token.
Spelling is all correct.
Callback.
We'll just put it in
there just so we
can see what happens.
Login.
Hello.
Right.
So we know we've got the access
token, that works.
Oo, oo, oo, oo, another bug.
PETE LEPAGE: And somebody just
said, and I don't know if this
is his suggestion on what your
bug is, but is it Instagram
API as the--
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, he just saw
me type that out, man.
There's another one.
But we fixed it, we spotted
it, reload app.
There we go.
So the bug we just had then a
second ago was I was looking
at the wrong part of the URL
string to actually parse out
the access token.
So here we go, boom, great.
We have an access token,
looks nice.
We're going to do the request.
Yeah, that looks OK.
Data, right, so--
oh, there's an error.
Oh man, what's that errors?
Can you see that there?
Is it visible on the screen?
PETE LEPAGE: It's visible
on screen.
PAUL KINLAN: So could not
load api.instagram.com.
Damn.
Well luckily, I know what that
is because that was the bug I
purposefully left in.
PETE LEPAGE: All right,
we like it when we
have purpose bug.
PAUL KINLAN: So obviously, the
thing that we're doing with
all these APIs is that we need
to basically ask the
permission to access
any arbitrary URL.
So we're going to basically say,
let me do the install and
reload, can I get access
to api.instagram.com?
So let's go back, get
to our extensions.
PETE LEPAGE: So now that's going
to say, this app can
access that particular
set of URLs.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, so when the
store integration all works
and everything, the user will
be asked at install time
whether they allow access to
that URL, essentially, which
is pretty nice.
It gives the user some
confidence about what the
application is doing.
Yeah, I was going to say you
can't normally access--
for instance, I can't access
Twitter right now inside this
application.
I can only access Instagram
because the
user's granted access.
PETE LEPAGE: And as a user, you
know that you're not going
to have some other app going
and sending your data to
places where you don't
expect it to go.
You know your data is being
handled responsibly.
PAUL KINLAN: Here we
go, look at this.
So the API request
has come back in.
The JSON object, it's
just a string at the
moment, has come back.
We will press play and--
it doesn't look as nice
as it did in my demo,
but there we are.
I think I generally know
what the problem is.
The response type has
come back and it's
not recognized its--
it should though.
Well anyway, it doesn't
really matter.
You have to trust me that
this is a JSON object.
It is.
Looks well, nice, and sexy.
And that's it.
That was basically
authenticating against
Instagram, and being able to
query it, with a get request
admittedly.
You could change it to a post
request and things should
still work.
As long as you've got access
to the access token, you
should be able to do the things
that you need to do
inside your APIs.
This isn't just restricted to
Instagram, obviously things
like Twitter, anything that
sports OAuth 2.0 generally
should work.
And the really nice thing about
this is the actual-- if
we go back to the code for
just two seconds--
the actual core, the core logic
is constructing the
variables itself, the things
that you want to call and how
you want to call it, and then
the final thing is the
experimental.ide
ntity.launchWebAuthFlow.
And that's the brunt of the API,
and we didn't have that
many servers in place to do
anything, we just called it.
PETE LEPAGE: We were able to go
in and grab somebody else's
service, and start pulling
stuff down, and
into our own app.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes, exactly.
It's pretty interesting,
it's pretty exciting.
We've only just kind of, me in
particular, has only just
really started playing
with this against
other external services.
But I've seen people in
hackathons update these, call
these different services and
just start to use the identity
API pretty quickly.
Obviously, we'll have more
information about the Google
authentication against
individual
services at a later date.
We'll do a Hangout around
that as well.
That's actually pretty
interesting as well.
PETE LEPAGE: That works today?
Like if somebody wanted to play
with that, it's under the
experimental API, does
it work today?
PAUL KINLAN: The Google one?
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: It does, but you
need to request a key, and
there's a whole lot of potential
changes that might
happen in the near future around
the experimental API,
around the Google
authentication.
So hold on just a little
bit with this.
The interesting thing is you
could probably implement and
integrate with Google services
relatively easy with this
third party OAuth flow, because
OAuth 2.0 has this
concept of scopes, and we have
this concept of scopes as well
in our authentication
protocol.
So you can probably do
it with this as well.
It's just not kind of a
seamless, if that make sense.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, that
makes perfect sense.
PAUL KINLAN: But it's a nice
seamless API for what it is.
So that's it.
I really want to know why it
didn't come out as nice as it
did in my other tester.
Doesn't matter, we'll
leave it, I'm happy.
PETE LEPAGE: That's OK.
So the link for those of you
who have questions is up on
screen right now, so you could
ask your questions if you want
to know a little bit more
about what's going on.
As well, if you want to go have
a look, Paul's uploaded
these samples already.
So if you want to go and play
with this, I just popped the
sample URL up on screen right
now so that if you want to go
play with it-- did you get it?
PAUL KINLAN: Yes.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PAUL KINLAN: I didn't turn
it into a JSON, a proper
JavaScript object, the
left of the screen.
And it turns out strings are
proper JavaScript object,
which is why it double encoded
everything, so there we go.
PETE LEPAGE: There you go.
All right, can we
actually see it?
Let's see it running.
PAUL KINLAN: It's there.
Do you not trust me?
PETE LEPAGE:There we go.
Now we can see it.
That's pretty.
PAUL KINLAN: Whee!
PETE LEPAGE: Yay.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, nice job.
It's pretty cool.
PETE LEPAGE: But could
you do it with two
spaces instead of four.
Four is a little too many.
I'm kidding.
PAUL KINLAN: Just for
you, anything.
PETE LEPAGE: Aww,
you're so sweet.
So why don't we grab one of the
first questions that we
have, and I'll take the stab
at this first question,
because it's, I think, a
really good question.
Unfortunately I don't have a
really great answer for you
today, I can give you an answer,
but I want to dive
into it more in a coming Chrome
Apps Office Hours.
This is from Tommy in Illinois,
and Tommy wants to
know what the status of
Native Client SDK and
packaged apps is.
And, Tommy, as far as I know you
can actually start playing
with them today, though
it's still somewhat
experimental on that.
Either next week or the week
after, we're going to do our
Chrome Apps Office Hours
specifically on this topic.
We've got one of the great guys
from they Native Client
team who's going to be joining
us to talk about this.
He's going to dive into this
in a lot more detail.
So keep an eye out, it's either
next Tuesday or the
following Tuesday, I don't
remember specifically
which one it is.
But Tommy, have a peek, we'd
love to have you join us for
that, and we'll dive into a
lot more the good, nitty
gritty details.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, it's cool.
What we've seen so
far is cool.
It'll be an exciting one.
It'll be good.
PETE LEPAGE: So Paul, I'll pass
this next one on to you.
From Swader in Croatia, is this
authentication mechanism
limited to just packaged apps,
or does it work for
extensions as well?
PAUL KINLAN: So I've not tried
it in extensions, however it's
not under the Chrome.app
namespace, so there's a good
chance that it'll work.
it just needs to be tested.
It doesn't take that much to
actually go off and test it.
I might go and test
it in a minute.
Yeah, I've not tested it.
It'd be nice if it does because
extensions needs this
type of API too, and I wouldn't
be surprised if it
did work, but I've
not tested it.
PETE LEPAGE: So Swader, one of
the things I'd recommend you
do is go post that question
to our email list which is
chromium-apps, chromium hyphen
apps at chromium.org.
You can go join there, you can
keep up to date with some of
the latest stuff on what's going
on, you can see this all
the great conversations.
We've got announcements about
all of the new features that
get released.
Right now this is experimental
so certainly it'll move out of
experimental.
When that happens, we will be
sure to let everybody know
through our mailing
list as well.
So with that I think that's
sort of the end of our
questions in great
demo today, Paul.
Thank you very much
for joining again.
PAUL KINLAN: I'll make it
a nice, proper looking
app soon, as well.
I just think it's a nice
little demo to
show you what happens.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, absolutely.
Now, if people want to go and
download this, they want to
try this on their own,
so the URL is there.
They're going to have to change
the secret key, and
they're going to have set
themselves up as a developer
on Instagram.
Isn't that correct?
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, it's
pretty simple process.
They've got really nice
documentation as well.
You basically just go to the
instagram.com/developer, click
register your application.
I've just actually deleted my
client key now, just in case.
PETE LEPAGE: So for those of
you who wanted to have a
little fun with it, sorry.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah,
I mean it's cool.
You go to Instagram, any kind
of third party service site,
you should be able to, so as
long as they support OAuth
2.0, you will be able to pretty
much use the exact code
that we've got today, and
just go from there.
I'll tell you what though,
if you do have any other
applications, any other
authentication methods that
you do use inside your own
services, let us know because
we would like to make sure that
this API works for you
guys, right.
So just catch us on
Google+, or email.
I'm paulkinlan@google.com.
PETE LEPAGE: I'm petele.
PAUL KINLAN: We're our
names pretty much
everywhere else on the web.
Just get access to us, post on
the forum, let us know what
you want to do with the
authentication API and the
identity API because we think
it's going to be key, and it's
going to be absolutely awesome,
but we need to make
sure that it works
for you guys.
PETE LEPAGE: Absolutely.
All right well, Paul,
thank you for
joining us from London.
Have a wonderful evening.
It's, what, almost 6 o'clock
there tonight.
PAUL KINLAN: It's already 6:00
o'clock and I've got another--
well, I'm not going tell you
how long I've got left, but
yeah, it's a long time.
PETE LEPAGE: Well, Paul, thanks
for joining us, and
thanks to all of you guys
for joining us.
We hope you have a wonderful
day, and we will see
you guys next week.
Same time, same place.
Take care, everybody.